entonces estás en clase de matemáticas
en los triángulos triángulos y no se el
profesor sigue diciendo palabras y se
supone que tienes que hacer algo con los
tribunos pero la verdad no me acuerdo
que son esas cosas y está aburridísimo
en unos triángulos demás y voy a dibujar
tus triángulos por separado pero
entonces se sienten solitos y están
mucho más contentos cómo se abrazan
informan una fiesta de triángulos todo
el mundo sabe que a los triángulos les
encantan las fiestas algunas veces se
juntan y hacen triángulo merados si
sigues agregando triángulos en el mismo
lado se vuelve curvo y espiral o puedes
alternar los y se quedan muy derechitos
de hecho como se supone que todos los
lados de los triángulos son líneas
rectas y cada triángulo está encima de
la línea recta que es el otro lado del
triángulo anterior entonces la línea
entera debería de ser una línea recta si
éstos realmente fueran triángulos pero
como está checa esto prueba que esto
realmente no son triángulos
con que la fiesta se puso demasiado
intensa y al menos no están haciendo
matemáticas y hablando del rey de roma
el maestro sigue hablando acerca de
tipos de trigo nos y se supone que estás
tomando apuntes crista es mucho más
interesado en los tipos de triángulos a
los que ya conoces perfectamente hay
triángulos gordos tengo los puntiagudos
triángulos perfectos triángulos
rebanadas de queso que son como los
triángulos puntiagudos pero simétricos
como una rebanada de queso o de pastel
los triángulos hiper puntiagudos son
súper divertidos cuando los apila es en
pilares y en torres de triángulos puedes
poner todas las puntas apuntando en una
sola dirección pero se empezará a caer
hacia esa dirección así es que es bueno
poner algunos triángulos en la otra
dirección antes de que llegues demasiado
lejos te darás cuenta muy rápido que
entre más flaco sea el triángulo agrega
menos desviación al pilar para compensar
una gran desviación puedes poner un
triángulo no tan flaco apuntando hacia
el otro lado pero si lo que quieres es
enfocar la torre de triángulos para
navegar la alrededor de tu nariz
entonces sigue alternando los lados pero
haciendo los triángulos que apuntan
hacia donde tú te quieres dirigir un
poco menos flacos
la parte sencilla de las torres de
triángulos es que en realidad sólo una
parte del triángulo es importante para
la torre y ese es el lado puntiagudo los
otros dos ángulos pueden ser gordo y
flaco o flaco y gordo o del mismo tamaño
si es una rebanada de queso y no cambian
al resto de la torre a menos que la
parte de arriba termine siendo demasiado
amplia porque entonces tienes dos partes
muy puntiagudas y no queda claro en cuál
de ellas deberías de continuar la torre
ambas en lugar de llamarle elgordoyflaca
deberías empezar a usar palabras
encriptadas para no detonar el detector
de pensamientos no matemáticos de tu
profesor así es que escoges dos palabras
del pizarrón obtusos y agudos que por
una increíble coincidencia resulta que
significa justo ángulo gordo y ángulo
flaco te juro que no lo hice a propósito
por supuesto que hay todo tipo de
triángulos lo cual no tiene sentido
porque entre más obtuso se vuelva un
ángulo más agudo se vuelven los otros
dos y si haces un triángulo más agudo
con el mismo perímetro tienes más área y
al parecer esa es una cualidad obtusa y
ahora
puedes seguirle llamando rebanada de
queso o de pastel a un triángulo
equilátero porque estos se ven más como
empanadas no el punto es que la
terminología de los triángulos es
truculenta pero al menos no estás
poniendo atención a las ecuaciones de
las que el profesor está hablando esas
cosas raras de unas funciones
trigonométricas la verdad yo prefiero
mil veces pensar acerca de las funciones
de los triángulos y ya conocemos algunas
o sea están los signos y los co signos
fueran con signos pero suficiente con
esta tangente al tema la cosa a la que
si hay que ponerle atención es que
afecta a tu tenglo y como si empiezas
dibujando el próximo triángulo de tu
torre de triángulos de esta forma para
cuando llegues a este punto ya sabes
exactamente cómo va a ser todo el
triángulo porque solo continuas a este
lado hasta que cruce esta otra línea
invisible y después dibujas el resto de
hecho puedes hacer toda una torre de
triángulos apilando puros pedazos de
triángulos y añadiendo las puntas
después para ver qué pasa
pueden ocurrir algunos problemas si
empiezas un triángulo así puedes ver que
nunca se va a cerrar sin importar qué
tan lejos extiendas las líneas y como
este triángulo no es
llamémosle el 'triángulo de las
bermudas' esto pasa cuando dos ángulos
del triángulo miden más de 180 grados y
como todos los ángulos en triángulos
suman 180 que por cierto que al
verificar muy fácil rompiendo los puntos
del triángulo y alineando las para que
formen una línea eso significa que si
dos ángulos miden 120 grados el otro
ángulo está en algún otro lado siendo
menos 60 por supuesto que tú no tienes
ningún problema siendo un triángulo de
las bermudas en una esfera donde los
ángulos de un triángulo siempre miden
más de 180 grados aunque el tercer punto
podría estar en australia lo cual está
muy bien a menos de que tengas miedo de
que los monstruos marinos se vayan a
comer a tu triángulo en fin es divertido
apilar triángulos en una torre y se ve
bonito cuando haces espirales pero
deberías de tener cuidado porque si no
pones atención va a chocar consigo misma
así es que más vale pensar muy bien en
esos ángulos y si lo haces bien en lugar
de obtener un choque desastroso obtienes
un anillo o puedes construir otro
círculo de triángulos empezando con un
polígono extendiendo los lados en una
dirección y después triangulando
alrededor para obtener esta especie de
trenzado
y después tal vez deberías agregar más
diagnosticamos un último juego empieza
con un asterisco y después triángulo en
una dirección sombre a los ángulos
obtusos para que se vea más padre
extiéndelo con otra capa detengo los y
con otra y otra y si sombreadas la parte
interna de los triángulos está
garantizado que será una increíble
fiesta de triángulos y hay todo tipo de
fiestas de triángulos a punto de suceder
a los triángulos tan simples pero tan
bonitos la esencia de la segunda
dimensión el objeto fundamental de la
geometría euclidiana los tres puntos que
definen un plano puedes quedarte con tus
formas exóticas y complejas están todas
formadas por triángulos triángulos y
secta este cuadrado en triángulos forma
arreglos simétricos algunos remanentes
de la geometría esférica e hiperbólica
triángulos que se ramifican en árboles
binarios y fractales y los números
incrementan exponencialmente con cada
iteración hacia el infinito triángulos
con la proporción correcta formando la
perfecta espiral dorada los amplios
triángulos isósceles con triángulos
equiláteros en el tercio del medio de
los lados exteriores de los triángulos
equiláteros hasta el infinito y obtiene
así un copo de nieve cuya frontera es la
curva de
con 1º infinito continua en todos lados
pero diferenciable en ningún punto y con
dimensión fractal lo 4 entre los 3
el profesor está caminando hacia acá es
hora de pretender que estamos haciendo
matemáticas
esta es una traducción al español de un
vídeo hecho por by hart muy
probablemente puedes encontrar una liga
al vídeo original en la descripción de
este vídeo en youtube echarle un ojo
porque está muy divertido